environ 45% du trafic d'air france
europe a été assurée aujourd'hui un
nouveau conflit est apparue entre les
pilotes d'air inter qui doivent être
intégrés erp france et leur président
est christian blanc reportage sébastien
guibert daniel hofer le bagage le plus
utile quand on voyage un jour de grève
c'est la patience les yeux rivés sur les
écrans de contrôle des vols surchargé
retardés et annulés un avion pour la
rabine ion les avions sont complets a
pas de placement devra prendre une
voiture pour redescendre
comme je fais lorient paris clermont
ferrand c'est pas très commode ce recul
est plus pratique on va rester patiente
en à peine 45 % des vols de la compagnie
air france europe ont pu être assurés
aujourd'hui les liaisons pour nice
marseille toulouse ont été
particulièrement perturbée six
allers-retours seulement pour chacune de
ces villes contre 25 en temps normal
les pilotes grévistes entendent dénoncer
la façon dont la direction d'air france
selon eux mènent la fusion avec l'ex air
inter la question des plans de carrière
des pilotes des deux compagnies est
alors sur révélatrice monsieur blanc a
demandé une commission de faire une
trame de faire une étude et il s'était
engagé à réunir l'ensemble des
organisations professionnelles pour
obtenir le consensus le plus large
il ne l'a pas fait il ne dialogue plus
il ya plus de dialogue social avec le
personnel derrière
les mêmes qui il y a encore quelques
mois était contre la fusion ont
aujourd'hui des exigences sur l'accès
aux long courriers
alors que s'il n'y a pas eu fusion le
problème de l'accès au long courrier ne
se serait pas posée les pilotes
grévistes en poursuivant leur mouvement
demain toute la journée veulent imposer
à christian blanc de nouvelles
discussions sur leur formation au vol
long courrier mais aussi sur l'avenir de
toute l'entreprise